the guards were asking you about this
black soul no but it is yes
he was a renegade herodrum dismembered
by he must retrieve it
i do not like this we can murder her
we rescued leah's mother the witch
adria she told us of the black soul
stone
an artifact that could destroy evil
forever of all mortals
i have been given the task of retrieving
[Music]
it
it's disgusting i've seen that woman
going in and out of the sewers
it's quite a maze down here isn't it
listen to me i cannot talk for long but
gods are constantly watching me emperor
khan forgive me for my behavior at court
the gods would have killed me had i
sided with you but i will help you now
as i can
you must be headed to the oasis
the loud entrance is strong but now
you've given me a chance
perhaps my only chance
how can you
why should i type
not enough fury uh
[Applause]
you're right
i need fury
an incredible feat
battlefield commander of all demons
having defeated the angels many times in
the eternal conflict across pandemonium
and the prime evils in the demonic civil
war
if the lord of sin ever assaults our
realm
we truly have much to fear
by the light i've never seen a place
like this
more fuel
oh
i need fury
oh
you cannot stand before
[Music]
three centuries ago a much smaller
calvium depended upon small wells for
its water
then came the mysterious salvo
an oasis of unparalleled splendor
located in an area previously thought to
be desert
asking only that his name be permanently
affected help me please
someone help i'm being robbed quiet you
fooled
you think you can save this man you have
sealed your
feet
the master commands us to capture more
slaves immediately
go to the oasis and abduct villagers
kill any who resist that way we shall
both gain allies
and destroy enemies to allow you the
privilege of buying them instead
why is that our motivations of one
another
no way
never wrote about this
you wilt against my blows
impossible
these creatures won't go down easily
i need beauty bulcatos guides my hands
i can't
nothing
no way
more fury
impossible
i need fury
god
so
impossible
we step out in one week
how far has cool's madness driven how
much
power has he accumulated in his mad
quest
i can only hope we are not too late
i need to go back
if you keep holding back then you'll
never improve
ah leah are you all right
yes i think so i'm sorry to push you
like this
but it will all be for the best in the
end
i know
it is time leah cast the spell
i live again
zoltan cool we need you
to activate the black souls though we
would use it to trap the last two
lords of hell